[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive in the next
half hour we'll see what's making the
headlines with journalist and author
christina patterson and deputy political
editor of the scottish daily mail rachel
watson uh so let's see what's on some of
those front pages uh the observer leads
with the growing crisis in ukraine
reporting that secret talks are underway
between western allies to arm the
ukrainian resistance forces in the event
of a russian invasion
the sunday telegraph follows suit with a
warning from home secretary pretty patel
of a possible cyber attack against
british interests as russia flexes its
military might
defiant boris will axe all covet rules
reads the front of the express as it
looks at revisions in coronavirus
restrictions due next week
meanwhile the sunday times claims
billionaires have joined boris johnson's
secret advisory board its headline
revealed the wealthy donors with the
pm's ear
the mirror reports that the home office
is looking into allegedly racist
whatsapp messages sent between staff who
work at a firm which does important work
for its department
car sick reads the front of the sunday
people it's as it looks into uh
reactions to another of controversial
comedian uh jimmy carr's recent jokes
and there's a reminder that by scanning
the qr code you'll see on screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by journalist
and author christina patterson and
political uh deputy political editor of
the scottish daily mail rachel watson uh
welcome to you both thanks for being uh
with us this evening uh let's start with
the observer the first first front page
there that we looked at west plans to
arm resistance if russian forces occupy
uh ukraine this after boris johnson
headed to munich uh and warned uh of
what could happen a generation of
bloodshed and misery uh if uh if the
west stood uh by
i mean the implication here is that the
us is already willing to arm a
resistance in ukraine uh i wonder rachel
watson if you think uh the uk would
follow suit
i think it's a really interesting piece
and here from the observance and you can
see this is really intensified this
weekend around what is going to happen
and when could this invasion happen as
it does seem
pretty likely now by the comments that
we've heard made from lots of leaders
who are all gathering in munich and this
piece is discussing as you say it sounds
pretty likely that the united states
have already made up their minds that
they will
help the ukraine the ukraine government
and they will help arm and whether that
is something that the uk government want
to do now i do think these discussions
will be being had by western governments
and western leaders at the moment what
do we do if russia does invade ukraine
what if this does lead to the outbreak
of war and we've heard a lot of talk
around sanctions for example over the
last few weeks and we heard the
ukrainian
president talking today in munich and he
said why are you waiting for sanctions
you should be doing something now
to those western allies and i think we
will be getting to the point now if the
governments really do think that
vladimir putin is going to send troops
in and invade ukraine they will be
having those discussions over what can
we do what can we do to help ukraine and
what would be the right action to take
without going too far how do we do that
and i think those are what you know we
will see play out in the coming days as
this does i think begin to escalate even
more and it seems to be gathering pace
as well certainly uh uh the ukrainian
president zelinski's saying uh that what
was happening looked a little bit like
appeasement echoing the words from the
defence secretary ben wallace who last
week said there was a sniff of munich uh
in in the air i wonder to what extent
you think uh christina patterson that
the
the sort of hangover from the chaotic
exit from afghanistan uh that we saw in
the summer that how much of an effect
that is having on u.s policy at the
moment but also on uk policy uh a sort
of desire not to repeat the mistakes
that were made then
i think it's really hard to know i think
it's a really terrifying moment i mean
we we just haven't been in a situation
most of us alive haven't been
in a situation
like this because this is the first
threat of actual war in europe uh beyond
a civil war since the second world war
and it's very hard to know what anyone
is up to actually i mean we don't really
know but we know that putin
apparently is
about to invade ukraine that the
evidence seems to be overwhelming what
we don't really know is exactly why he
wants to do that and we don't really
know how far the absolute mess the
moral atrocity that was our abandonment
and the us's abandonment of afghanistan
we don't know how far that is featuring
in this and to be honest we also don't
know how far boris johnson's desire to
cling on to
his job is featuring in this because
what we do know is that he is someone
who is very keen to exploit any
situation and opportunity for his own
political gains
and although i am sure i i'm absolutely
sure that he like any british leader one
could imagine would not want there to be
a war in ukraine and would not want
democracy to be threatened in the way
that russia is clearly doing i don't
think i mean i think what is clear is
that he wants to look like churchill um
because that he's always wanted to look
like churchill and he's written a
biography about churchill and he sees
himself as a great kind of leader so
it's very very hard to disentangle any
of this we also know of course that the
uk has been one of the chief launderers
of russian money for some years and you
know we have been welcoming
billionaire oligarchs and friends of
putin into london with open arms they
own a lot of property in london we've
given them preferential visas so it and
uh we we know that there has been plenty
of russian funding of towards satori
parties so frankly a lot of this looks
like um you know
shutting the stable door after the horse
is bolted but the situation for those in
ukraine i can't begin to imagine what it
must be like now sitting in kiev knowing
that any minute any day your city your
country is about to be invaded and
people will be killed is absolutely
horrifying and of course the nature of
the war that might come if it does come
uh is is potentially different from what
we've seen before we uh you know there
is talk of these false flag operations
uh the evacuations at the moment from
the eastern uh parts of the separatist
eastern parts of ukraine apparently
under the guise of the fact that there
could be uh some sort of an attack on
those uh on those regions again thought
to be false but at least you know for
optic's sake those people being uh
evacuated there and now of course this
cyber attack so the sunday telegraph on
its front page has britain warned of
cyber attacks as russia flexes military
mike now we always knew
this would be potentially a hybrid war
if it does come
and now it seems that britain
even if it didn't want to involve itself
by arming ukrainian uh fighters is
involved potentially in a cyber uh
capacity uh rachel watson i mean here
i'm just here it says in the in the
sunday telegraph mr johnson pledge has
pledged to make it impossible for
companies of strategic importance uh to
the russian state to raise finance in
the city if the kremlin orders an
invasion uh but what happens if the uk's
infrastructure is targeted as a result i
mean
both sides have a lot up their sleeves
here don't they
yeah and i think we saw that there was a
tweet that went out from the russian
embassy that said you know spoke about
sanctions and said
this is something that we we know how to
deal with it's happened to us before and
so there will be that on the minds of
the government you know how will they
look at sanctions i know the u.s
government we're talking a little bit
more about certain pipelines for example
but then there's the ramifications for
that and if you do block pipelines or
you don't allow you place sanctions on
them how do they then hit the west
access to oil to energy and also what
what are the consequences of that
because that as you say it's not just
going to be a war if it ends up as war
that is fought on the front line that is
for through military action it will be
we know that and there have been
concerns previously and now heightened
concerns as the telegraph reports about
russian um
hacking for example and that cyber
security issue around this and the
pretty patel's written for the telegraph
about this um in tomorrow's paper and
she's raised real concerns um
about the government actually expects
these attacks to happen and that the
national cyber security
agency has spoken to certain sectors and
certain key sectors communication
utility and food um industries around
how to improve security around their
cyber um set up to make sure that if
they are targeted they have the best
possible defense
but of course
but of course that would demand uh
funding and it's extraordinary to think
that they wouldn't have thought about
that before i want to quickly mention
the sunday times with putin issues go
order for war in ukraine uh this time
the uk saying four senior figures in
government have confirmed that they also
expect a multi-pronged russian assault
to begin any day our intelligence they
say is consistent with the americans it
seems like putin really has made that
decision and now uh really the question
here according to the sunday times
simply whether uh the russians will take
a bite out of ukraine or launch a
full-scale uh invasion i'm going to
leave it there for this as mass as we
can talk about with ukraine but we've
got to uh take a break coming up after
that break do billionaires have the
listening ear of the prime minister you
heard christina talking about that story
in the sunday times we'll have more on
that
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now are the journalist
and author christina patterson and the
deputy political editor of the scottish
daily mail rachel uh watson thank you
again for being with us let's go
straight back into our stories this time
on covid and the relaxation to uh all
kovid rules so the sunday express
splashing with this on its front page pm
says it's time we learn to live with the
virus defiant boris will axe all covet
rules uh on that front page though
medics warning the move is premature and
a big leap in the dark uh rachel do you
think it's too soon
well this is a highly controversial move
um that the prime minister is going to
make and just you know this will only be
in england um because as health is a
devolved issue so for instance in
scotland that would be nicola sturgeon
who would make that decision she's not
at this point i don't believe she'll
also make a speech this week setting out
how she wants to move out of the
pandemic but i don't expect her to line
with boris johnson on this um but boris
johnson seems to really be going for
this he wants to find a way
for the country to live with the virus
which is the point that we're going to
have to get to at some point but the
concern has been expressed expressed by
health experts that around this ditching
of the legal requirement to self-isolate
if you have the virus up until now
you've had to legally self-isolate for
it's been reduced to five days or seven
days in scotland so there's been that
requirement that you have to but now it
will be down to that personal
responsibility you will be asked just to
make that decision to self-isolate
rather than being forced to and that's
where the concern comes from are we
moving too fast with this i mean if you
look inside the express they have a poll
which shows that actually um a lot of
people in the country are a lot more
concerned about this than boris johnson
they're a lot more holding back a little
bit more i think half of people say that
they would continue to self-isolate half
say that they will still avoid busy
places so i don't know if boris johnson
you know he will see this as a big
positive move we are getting through the
pandemic but whether that is too
fast when we still have huge case
numbers right across the country growing
and people are still getting this virus
in huge numbers and how will these how
will it j's affect that going forward
certainly and it is very uh interesting
with your uh hat on as the scottish
daily mail to see how this is going to
be received by the other devolved
nations let's quickly talk about the
sunday times front page article as well
revealed the wealthy donors with uh the
prime minister's ear christina patterson
who are they and why are they called
shadowy
well i must say in two years of
extremely shocking stories emerging
about our government not least the party
gate scandals which have rocked the
government for the last few months this
is one of the most shocking stories to
have broken and it's about i think 14
very wealthy people who have been um
giving money to the tory party who've
been appointed to a so-called advisory
group and the article says that these 14
people their collective wealth amounts
to 30 billion pounds and they have been
given special access to downing street
to meetings chaired by lord lister